Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast from Monday fucking Monday,
either year,
August 15th,
2016 what's going on?
How are Ya?
Oh,
freckles finished his tour,
finished his tour strong.
Um,
I did my last two nights,
one Cologne,
Germany,
and then the other aunt twerp and Torben,
uh,
Belgium
got a frog in my throat here.
Um,
just amazing shows and I got to tell you something.
I want a special thank you to the people who came out in Germany.
I fucking did my Hitler Shit and I thought that they were going to pull back.
They loved it and I don't mean loved it.
Like,
yeah,
bring the guy back.
They had a great sense of humor about it and um,
oh yeah,
it was great too.
And then all my other shit too was working rows of just a great show.
And um,
I learned a lot about the city.
Oh No,
you didn't bill,
you were there for fucking like 17 hours.
I went on their Wikipedia page,
Cologne,
Germany,
and I found out that it was one of the most bombed cities of a World War II.
So it was this weird thing where it was this really old city,
but everything was brand new because the allied's fucking blew everything up
except for this one church,
you know,
which I don't understand how it survived.
It's got the really tall fucking Spiers,
you know,
it was just sitting there.
It had like,
must have had like Mayweather fucking head movement.
I don't know how it avoided it.
I asked her,
I don't get how like Cologne,
Germany somehow got bombed more than Hiroshima or Nagasaki.
I mean they got fucking,
is it,
cause it was just one,
one bomb that really redefined the old right there.
Fred,
you know,
when you drop a fucking atom bomb on somebody that that is,
that is probably the ultimate right there,
Fred,
where I'm Cologne.
Germany was more just like,
do you remember that fight?
Uh,
what the fuck George Saint Pierre had where he just kept punching that other guy
right in his fucking eye.
We Jab,
Jab,
and he kept hitting him in the exact same fucking place.
That's what we did to Cologne,
Germany where Japan,
that was more like a,
an Anderson silver.
Well,
you know,
when you stand in there and you'd think he's going to throw a jab and then he
somehow gives you an uppercut with his foot.
Is it bill?
Is that what at the atomic bomb was like?
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
Um,
anyways,
so,
uh,
the tour finished up strong and uh,
I don't hear a lot of people ever saying that they go to Belgium,
you know,
at least in the states.
Um,
Jesus Christ,
it was fucking incredible.
Um,
the number one thing that was so fucking cool about Belgium is there beer
glasses of the shit.
Every fucking beer.
It's like,
it has its own God damned chalice that it puts it in.
Just,
I dunno,
we just psychologically it all tastes better.
I bought some chocolates there from my lovely wife
and now I'm going to be on vacation here.
All right.
But fucking,
oh,
Billy fat again is hitting the gym.
I did,
uh,
did 45 minutes on the,
the elliptical yesterday and then went right into town and got myself a large
pizza that I ate by myself
and he is laughing at me.
Then I had a coca cola with that.
What else did I have?
I,
what else did I,
and I had a fucking gelato.
Oh.
And I had to call cal Calamari how they said it,
right.
I'm like,
can I get some fried Calamari?
And the guy goes,
Calamari.
I'm like,
yeah,
the way you said it to what you said sounds great the way I say it.
Just fucking terrible.
So,
um,
that's what I had for lunch.
So I should have done four hours and 45 minutes on the fucking elliptical.
My fucking belly is so God damn round right now.
It's ridiculous.
You know,
it was hilarious.
The,
uh,
the Italian fellow
that picked me up at the airport and by pick me up,
I'm just mean,
he just had a great opening line and I couldn't resist
the taxi guy.
He fucking said the funniest shit was saying how hard he was working during the
summer.
And he goes,
he goes,
that's why my body,
it goes,
it's white like the Mozzarella.
And I was going,
I fucking died laughing because I have been caught my legs.
I had been called every a fucking Casper fucking yard sticks,
you know,
in Golf,
uh,
chalk legs,
all this shit.
No one ever said your legs.
The white,
like the Mozzarella.
You know,
it's funny about Mozzarella.
Is it sweaty too?
It's all fucking wet wipe.
It's only redeeming qualities.
It tastes so good.
But if it just didn't taste good,
you just be like a ball of white slime and a,
yeah.
When I'm on the elliptical,
I'm like a big red fucking ball.
Mood.
Crl,
um,
came in.
What did you say?
Remember when I said you had legs dipped and flower?
Yes,
I remember all of those.
I remember all of them vividly.
What are you doing?
Are you going to be on the podcast?
He just going to lay there giggling in the
ground.
Can I,
can I do both?
No.
You know what?
It was near.
You had that little fucking doughnut.
That's what puts you down on Mount.
I fucking hate donuts.
How do you hate?
I like,
I like kind of mighty.
I like the Margarita Pizza.
The colors of the Italian flag meeting.
You think that was it?
It was so little.
It was like,
it wasn't even a real size donut.
It wasn't even the size of a Munchkin from Dunkin.
Yeah,
it was.
It was smaller than the exact size of that.
Eat One of those.
It was smaller than a Munchkin.
This is why I don't like donuts.
Okay.
Most of them stink like that one.
That one was not good.
I thought it was good.
All right.
Well,
okay.
Fair enough.
All right.
But you eat one of those in your body just goes,
what the fuck?
Yeah,
it's the ultimate.
What the fuck?
Fruit.
It's sifting through it.
Where's the nourishment?
It's nothing,
Nini.
I'm eating pizza and Calamari.
Yeah.
You know even that shit makes sure that that the Gullah mark that was fucking
light.
Yes it was.
Even though it was bad for you and all that shit,
but fucking don't.
At least there's some sort of protein and there's someone in there.
There's a fucking squid.
Is that what it is?
So yeah,
it's squid.
Squid.
Yeah,
it's all right.
So once you get past the bat or knowledge shit in there,
there was something that has some sort of nutrition.
Eat a fucking doughnut.
It's just like no,
it's all sugar and doe.
Yeah.
I eat one of those and I feel like I,
uh,
I was up early though,
too earlier than you.
So I feel like,
oh,
I know.
I realize that this whole fucking vacation
I finally get to sleep.
I haven't slept in like 10 days.
Okay.
Because you know,
I was going from country to country and then I was also drinking like fucking
Nick naulty in 48 hours.
Did he drink or is just sound like a drunk?
Um,
so I wasn't getting a lot of sleep,
so now I'm catching up on all that.
Do you know what you said,
nick?
Naughty and I thought,
Gary Busey,
they're interchangeable.
Right?
But one of them is crazy and the other one isn't right.
One of them is like normal.
Yeah.
But they're like,
they look,
they really look like each other.
They got a similar,
which is the same thing like the Spiderman guy and the hobbit.
Dude look the same to me.
Oh,
Toby McGuire and Elijah Wood.
Yeah.
So that's the petite men,
brown haired,
like blue wide boys that make like fantasy movies.
Right?
Yeah.
To me they're the same.
They're there.
The
Nick naulty and,
and,
and what's his face of Gary?
Gary Busey.
Elijah Wood and Tobey Maguire.
All right.
Wait,
what was the movie we were talking about yesterday?
It was one of a Hashtag Bibi's titles.
Uh
Oh,
right.
How I'm here.
Your computer.
Oh,
that's sick.
Yeah.
When I was in Germany.
Um,
but the story about the three nerds in the check then yeah.
You called it how I made her compete.
Yeah.
But I knew that was wrong.
I just kept thinking third rock from the sun.
Right.
I don't know why.
No,
what's the name?
There's no number on that show.
Big Bang theory.
Yeah,
but you kept called
how I met your computer.
This smart.
It's all of those sick cause I don't watch any of those sitcoms just cause,
uh,
I'm out of the loop with that stuff.
But I liked that show and I watched it,
but I just sent you a video of it cause I was in Germany and uh,
the tallest one of the kids there on on Big Bang theory just watching him and in
a German accent.
Oh Jim Parsons.
He's the one that wins all the MES.
So you liked you like big bath theory?
I've never,
I've never seen a single episode and it's like the biggest show,
Big Bang Bang.
I have not seen that single episode.
Well,
I don't know.
I enjoyed it.
I enjoyed watching it in German.
So anyways,
so nia has been falling asleep here at like nine o'clock,
10 o'clock at night.
Cause you're still jetlag.
And I know,
I,
you know,
I stay up late,
what does she do last night when after I fell asleep,
I sat outside on the chair and uh,
I watched a bunch of Billy squire videos.
I don't know how I got into that,
but I was sipping a little Johnnie Walker black over there and I was thinking,
I don't know,
I was just watching all these drum videos,
what's going down that little fucking rabbit hole there.
And um,
I was like,
I'm that guy that used to play
okay
for Billy squire that Kinda had a bond,
a mask field,
and I couldn't remember his name.
And then I looked it up.
So I have Bobby chew and art and he was from Brockton mass.
And um,
it was,
she,
you know,
she just was a fucking monster player.
I don't remember.
Um,
you know him,
she died really young.
He was only like 43,
I think he had like a heart attack.
So I just went to go put that,
you know,
I wanted to listen to him play and then I just was watching this Billy squire
shit,
like live in Detroit.
That guy was such a fucking rock star.
It's ridiculous.
Like I don't understand.
And everybody always talks.
He made this one video and everybody always talks about like,
do it ended his fucking career.
It was like that thing came out in the fucking eighties.
It was so in the eighties like
that,
nobody noticed most of the videos,
most of the videos from that time did not stand the test of time.
You know what I mean?
I,
but I hate when people try and go like,
oh,
like in the moment when that video came out,
everybody said to hell with Billy squire.
That's not what happened.
He just didn't have any more hits after that.
Um,
but even like,
I actually read a quote,
Martha Quinn,
what's going on?
When that video came,
I don't remember an adverse reaction to what she goes.
I thought it was Kinda cute,
which is not what you want to say,
but basically now you look at,
he's got like this Pastel fucking shirt on and he's just sort of stomping around
fucking record this apartment.
It's really bad.
If that's the case though.
What do like most rock videos in the 80s be like ripped to shreds?
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Well people,
yeah.
I don't know.
The horrible,
wait,
everybody does synchronize.
Fucking dancing,
licking your base.
Fucking doing the,
everybody doing that thing like they will fucking eating pussy.
They're not as,
yeah,
that's the thing.
Steve Vibe with this fucking double neck guitar and he's sitting there like
acting like he's fucking the guitar.
What's your funniest play in your favorite video from the 80s?
I have one.
Um,
it's money for nothing.
The animation?
No,
no,
but that's number two.
The first one is take on me by Aha.
But they weren't a rock band where they more pop where they considered pop.
Yeah.
Do,
do,
do in any,
in any Robert Palmer video with all the charity,
me take on me.
Me.
Oh,
oh God.
And any Robert Power radio with the like the half dozen shakes with the same
body type and the black slicked back hair.
The Red Lips,
the big titties.
I gotta be honest with you,
that video,
they,
those chicks did nothing for me.
Everyone was like,
oh my God.
It was just so fucking white dude.
It's like six of them.
Did you stand in there?
I was just like supermodels and they like,
I just find none of them could play an instrument fucking freaked out.
It was really funny how they all just fake plants.
Yeah.
They had this look on their face.
They hadn't got enough free drinks that night.
I told you I have made your fucking issues with women of that ilk.
I did just fucking just,
I respect them.
You're gorgeous.
You know what I mean?
But just like the fucking them,
the most boring people ever.
The worst fucking interviews ever.
You get a fucking model just sitting there.
They stay fucking stink.
They just look good.
It's just,
just shut up.
We just want to look at you.
You're like a fucking lamp that somebody wants to fuck.
But other than that,
you're useless.
You're fucking useless person.
So,
oh,
I,
I liked,
I liked the fucking who is,
I always liked the who is,
I like the flooding party girls.
All those checks.
Does the good looking girls do you like?
Yeah,
they look like they were fun.
Like if you showed up with like a 12 or fucking Budweiser's,
they'd fucking drink some with you in.
Someone was going to get a blowjob.
You watch the fucking Robert Palmer video.
It's like nobody's getting indexed.
Dick sucked here.
These fucking chicks is so up their own asses.
They're just,
Eh,
eh.
They probably all hated each other.
Yeah.
They don't want to go to a dive bar with,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
That too classy for that.
Until uncle Terry takes their pictures and all of a sudden they're getting a
three d look at a salt pepper.
Fucking pubes coming at him.
That fucking creep,
dude.
Anytime you're of a certain age and you start telling younger women to call you
uncle so and so and you're not fucking related to them,
that's a major,
you know,
one reason why I know about him was because you were in the fashion world.
He's,
he's so disgusting.
Yeah.
Anytime he takes Jesus chain.
Terry.
Yes.
What has that played out?
I know that whole styles play out.
What's your theme for this one?
All right.
It's like you're drugged up,
but you really want to fuck this old guy.
Do you remember more went into that book shop and we saw like the books that he
published before he started getting all this fame for like taking a picture of
Jared Leto.
It's literally him with a d,
His dick and some girl's face and him literally coming on a girl.
Like those were his whole books of them.
Those were his photographs at first.
I,
the only reason why I know the guy is the reason why I know who that guy is just
because of you.
Yeah.
This is the peep.
Anybody?
Yeah.
Calls himself uncle is either a fucking pervert or they think everything that
they say is fucking amazing.
Like Ted Nugent.
Just another tip from your uncle Ted.
I got the whole world figured out.
He's like,
he like,
he lives in like a tree fort and he shoots bears with arrows and then all of a
sudden then all of a sudden he knows how the world should work.
I just don't understand.
You know,
isn't he like,
yeah,
he's like a big
serving of a gun.
That.
Do you need some water?
What's going on over there?
Now I'm fine.
All right.
Clear my throat.
I pulled the fucking thing.
I me clear.
No tenure.
I respect anybody that knows how to fucking hunt.
Anybody knows how to hunt.
Everybody knows like guns and shit.
I think that's a really cool thing.
I feel like he's,
does he ha he hunts for food or does he kill a bear to put it on his living room
floor?
Both.
I have no idea.
You'd have to ask him why you hunch,
but I know he knows how to do it.
I think that's a cool thing.
And like,
uh,
you know,
and he's responsible gun owner.
He has a gun.
He doesn't go around shooting people.
What'd you go into his house?
She's going to blow your fucking head off.
I mean,
there you go.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's totally makes sense to me.
But just because I agree with that doesn't mean I need to listen to you and your
fucking fuck
it.
Yeah.
Well,
honest to your thoughts about our foreign policy with fucking whatever you want
to do,
but you can't deliver it in this fucking way.
That's another tip from your uncle bill.
Uncle.
I Dunno.
So anyways,
so I was,
I was on the Internet last night and I was looking at all this Billy squire
stuff.
Billy Squire live in Detroit.
The fucking guy's guitar playing total front man is interaction with the crowd.
I mean,
the guy was,
she just was fucking murder in it and he had this great band and I ended up
fucking went down this whole fucking thing.
I'm looking at Bobby chewing the ad and there's a book on him and stuff,
which of course I ordered on Amazon.
It's like 20 bucks,
got the hat cover.
And uh,
I remember I used to take drum lessons,
I can't remember the name of it,
but I used to take it in Brockton.
And um,
how long have you been taking drum lessons?
Well,
I took him for like three or four years in the early nineties.
And then I didn't take him again,
right until,
uh,
last year.
Mm.
Oh No,
wait a little bit.
When I was in New York,
I used to go,
I had a couple teachers at a
um,
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck was it called?
The fuck is that place called when we were dating it?
No,
before,
right now,
what app was I,
what happened was I started fucking plane and um,
I know I played like three,
four years.
Then I started taking some lessons and then right around
that time I started doing standup and then stand up was the thing,
like it's the thing that stopped me from being a great drummer.
Neil was time.
I didn't have the time and I didn't have the God given.
Right.
Have
I at the end of the big one,
I did not have the gift and I used to,
I thought if I just kept working,
working,
working at it,
I would somehow work my way into having the gift.
Do you say to yourself,
wait,
can I just ask you,
do you see yourself in your seventies like doing comedy in Vegas somewhere and
kind of doing like a don Rickles type of situation,
but then maybe you get behind the drums and sort of do like a musical comedy
thing?
Oh God.
But it's charming because you're old.
It would be so pathetic.
No,
it will be all in music.
I listened to welcome to the job
and you're wearing like,
no,
no.
Let's see.
No,
no.
Then have all the young hotties
singing going,
right.
Bill's got fun and games and then they'd come over.
Then they'd come over and they'd fucking pat my bald head.
Oh,
he's so adorable.
Um,
Nina,
I would kill myself.
I would jump off the welcome to Vegas sign.
I'm saying that now as a 48 year old,
who knows?
I'm like moving into your seventies eighties doing like a month or so residency.
We can move to Vegas for a couple months.
Yeah.
Just like the saddest scenario,
why they would pay you a good amount of money.
Why is that you think going to be going on tour and your seventies you think you
have me on the road like you are now?
I think I'm going to save my fucking money so I don't have to.
I don't like the only reason I'll be on the fucking road in my seventies as it
gets.
I want,
still want to be,
but I still felt like I had something to say but that might be my fucking age
was like,
I don't know what's up with these computers.
I'll still be bitching about the same shit,
but you're going to,
I know you you're going to still want to do comedy,
but you liked making people laugh.
I do it on a much smaller scale.
I'm fine with that,
but I'm not going to make a fucking ass and myself and have some Luau theme
fucking comedy show.
Oh,
please tell me your drag me off stage.
The day I show up and I'm in drag and I have like the coconuts over my fake
taste,
Caesar's palace presents.
Oh God,
that would be a nightmare.
No,
we can live in this.
We can live in a suite at Caesar's for like two months.
And you do your,
you know,
classic comedy.
It's telling jokes from 2020.
Well that's the thing.
You can't do classic comedy.
You can't go out.
Like I saw Don Rickles and Tony Orlando opened up and he was playing,
uh,
you know,
knock three times on this scene.
And I remember that fucking year.
You like psych,
you psych,
but like,
no one's psyched to hear a joke again that the already hurt.
They just go away.
I can't be like,
yeah,
right.
I don't know if you remember this,
but there was a president long time ago,
he stuck a cigar,
the car,
Monica Lewinsky.
And then you just start doing all that.
And then,
um,
then I do like a medley of styles.
That all influenced me.
I do the Eddie Murphy Laugh,
the Sam's Kinison yell the Seinfeld,
Whoa.
You know,
as the band plays underneath it.
Yeah,
exactly.
You know,
comedy and music can a lot of similarities.
There's a rhythm isn't a journey.
Okay,
I'm wearing Hawaiian shirts because I'm crazy.
What's,
what's he going to say next?
Yeah.
But you're not going to want to just rest on your laurels.
Even in your seven days,
you're going to still want to go out.
So I'm just thinking about I'm going to rest on my ass.
That's white,
like the moods rail,
but led the moves it out.
I would say rarely.
Um,
no,
I,
I don't get the concept of retiring.
Like if you retire,
you're just,
then you're just,
I would feel useless and I would just be like,
I'm going to die in about 10 days.
I would be one of those people.
If I'm retired I would be dead in a week because I'd just be like,
it's over.
I'm useless.
Why am I still here?
And I would go into an unbelievable depression.
That's what I mean.
I wouldn't die.
But you have to work in a capacity in which someone wants to see a 70 year old
comedian.
Okay.
And the place where people would want to see and pay to see a 70 year old
comedian is Las Vegas,
let's be real.
Or You could have like,
you know,
of a few nights run at a theater in New York.
Maybe.
But it's not like you're going to be going to all the comedy clubs like you're
doing now,
which is fine.
Um,
yeah,
I don't know.
All of that is really frightening.
I don't mean to frighten.
Yeah.
Wow.
It the end.
That's the end of your fucking life.
It's just the end.
Um,
I'll be there with you.
Don't worry.
Okay.
Yeah.
No,
I,
I picture my seventies and eighties.
Uh,
I definitely am wearing slippers.
Potson around the house.
Yeah.
And God willing,
you know,
the house is paid for.
I still have a nice car.
All right,
Holly and I'm going to be like half.
What do you think have does all day?
He probably putters around the house and his slippers.
Hmm.
Did somebody buy that house?
Somebody bought it and then that he was going to turn it,
but he wanted to turn it into something and so the deal didn't work out because
I think the thing is you can buy it,
but have,
has to live there until the end of his life.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
That's what's going,
I don't know.
Yeah,
I think they did an article on that.
You gotta,
you gotta buy his house for $100 million and it's a tear down,
which means he didn't keep it.
How do you not keep it up?
You know what?
Once he was in the fucking magazine business,
he started in the 50s and who would've known that the Internet would come along
and all these kids stop buying magazine,
all this free porn and all that,
and it just went down the fucking drain.
That's the other thing to Nia.
The lucky thing that I have being a comedian is people always want to laugh.
I think that that's the reason why not only is it survived all of these new
technologies,
it actually thrives because you know what I mean?
What's the,
what's the main shift that you watch on,
on the Internet?
You want to fucking laugh or jerk off to something?
Yeah.
That's the two big things and yeah.
Um,
comedy just,
it fits,
you know,
Joe can be really quick.
Guy Walks into a bar.
He said,
Mama Blind.
The guy said,
well,
but blue it done.
You get the fucking laugh in these kids with their,
their,
their fucking squirrel,
like intention spans.
It works.
So,
um,
I dunno how long ago or how long it works at this fucking level.
Uh,
but uh,
I dunno.
Yeah,
I'll,
that shit is fucking scary to me so I just keep,
uh,
just looking for my next special Nia and I got by the way,
I got it.
I got it worked out.
You do?
Yeah.
I know which ones I'm doing.
I know which ones I'm leaving out anyone's that I feel are like going to even
remotely be like considered,
uh,
like done before,
you know,
as much as I liked the aborted landing bit that I've been doing,
I'm not doing it because at the end of the day it's fucking airplane material
and that'll just be one where I'll just like,
I just have that one of my back pocket as far as like,
if I'm just somewhere one night and I'm sick of my act,
I'll just bust that one out again.
Although I feel like I told it and everything.
You can bring it back Caesar's when you're 70.
There you go.
It's a time with Joe.
Yeah.
Dying in a plane crush.
I've been at that one is just that one,
just a fun one to do.
And if fucking murderers,
everyone can relate to it and everything.
But I just kept seeing it back of my head.
I just kept going like,
you know,
this is,
this is just airplane material.
And then one night I went to flappers,
I'm not going to say who I saw him on stage and I was just,
and he had us
joke about an aborted landing and it,
mine was different enough but it just hit the same points,
you know,
the steward is not talking if fucking,
what's going through your head and all that.
And it just was like,
and um,
I was going to say something,
hey,
I Kinda got something like that.
But that was just like
I said,
you know,
online going to bother with that.
I'm just not going to do it.
But on this past tour when I went through Europe,
you know,
I broke it out probably 60% in the nights because it kills.
And I was also trying to get comfortable.
I just have to get a little comfortable over here to forget that I'm not in the
United States.
Um,
do you feel like a pretty effective of certain jokes?
Like with that one you were saying if someone had a similar premise that you're
kind of more willing to let it go,
but are there certain jokes that you just feel like,
you know,
you absolutely like no,
this is definitely going in the special knock.
Not Well,
not if I see somebody else doing something like I'm doing.
Um,
no I wouldn't do that because then I'm thinking,
well did they put theirs out yet or are they going to put theirs out?
And um,
I dropped the joke is what I do.
Um,
yeah.
Even if maybe you came up with a for not saying that this is the case with the
airplane one,
but if you feel like if you hear somebody do something about Caitlyn Jenner or
something like that.
Yeah.
Like even that one,
like as much as much fun as I've been having with that,
I don't think I'm doing that.
One of the Special,
Oh really?
Yeah.
Cause I got,
cause I got this other chunk of shit that I can do that's along the same lines.
Um,
now also I made fun of Caitlin when I was on Conan,
so that's already out there.
And then I also feel like it's just Kinda,
uh,
it's done.
I just feel like that that subject is,
I just want them up there when I'm up there,
when I'm doing the bit,
as much fun as I'm out.
The Fun that I'm having is,
is the crowd's reaction to what I'm saying.
But you know,
my heart of hearts,
I don't have any passion for it anymore.
I don't give a shit and she's not in the news anymore.
Right.
I don't give a fuck.
That's true.
It's just that one period when,
you know,
when they made that federal case about her fucking where she should pee and what
building and,
and uh,
that was just,
it was just such a lay up as far as like,
you know,
this is your fucking problem.
And like,
I don't know,
we'd just come back and Asian Shit.
And just seeing what those people are going through.
And then you come here.
Yeah.
And this fucking millionaire Olympic star is,
I dunno,
I know she doesn't have a show anymore.
They can't do the show.
It's kind of like it's done,
you know?
Yeah,
that's true.
It's gotta be killing them
to not have the show,
which is great for me if you're not interested,
if you're not interesting after you do something like that.
Well,
I mean,
that's like,
it's like it was boring as Bruce and she's boring is like,
it's just not,
there's nothing magical that happened.
Now that he's come out as transgender,
like there's nothing,
you know,
she's still a Republican.
He's still living in Malibu.
Still Boring.
It's just not,
she looks great,
but that was the best part.
I love the transgendered Republican.
Yeah.
I mean it's everybody getting mad.
I love,
they thought if you've got some,
he got some titties.
All of a sudden he'd be looking at the world differently.
She's exactly the same.
She just looks different and she's got a three
and a great hairstyle and great makeup.
That's it.
But it's the same person.
Nobody watched keeping up with the Kardashians to see Bruce.
I mean the guys had enough picking like he's obviously suffering here.
I think Caitlin is fine actually.
I think he's just fine.
Oh yeah,
she does just fine.
Yeah.
I think it gets a night.
Before Caitlyn goes to bed,
she puts on the Robert Palmer video and does those dances.
You know what I would actually love to see,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
Mom.
Photoshop and I'm Photoshop.
Please.
Will you please make my God,
please make Bill Robert Palmer and then a whole row of Caitlyn Jenner,
my old,
my old biggest show in the background playing in Sir.
Wow.
Right now.
Right.
I gotta do this.
I got to do some advertising.
Yeah.
All right.
Hey Nia,
have you heard,
have you heard about MVMT watches?
No.
We'll look when you're in your twenties and thirties.
Money can be tight.
The,
if you're not careful,
dressing well can quickly drain your bank account and we spending four to $500
on a department store watch.
Um,
there's some brands out there charging insane prices.
Can you not make noise in the background of God?
This is a professional podcast happening here.
There's some brands out there charging insane prices for watches that aren't
even worth it.
Well,
if you want to look great when you go out,
but still up money to buy him or her a drink,
checkout movement,
watches.com what does that him or her or me,
what does that mean?
Cause are they trying to suggest that women actually buy drinks?
Yes,
we do buy drinks.
When you're talking about now for men,
you're welcome.
Hey sailor,
can I
yet?
She is Sam Adams.
No,
but maybe you were out with a guy and you're just like,
here,
let me,
let me get this round.
And it was like,
oh,
this girl's cool.
Can you just say that again?
Hey,
let me get this round one more time.
let me get this Rahaman wow.
First of all,
I've known you for 12 years old.
Never heard anyone say that that was cheeto juice.
Beetlejuice Beetlejuice hey,
let me get this round.
I thought your dress,
but finish around in Texas.
Yeah,
they
good,
good job.
Jump out of that conversation very soon,
mark out conversation.
But I do recall in our dating days before
we sound like a fucking politician.
I do recall an incident.
Do me a favor.
I love you.
Just walk away.
Fuck you.
There you go.
Right there.
Capitulation.
Fuck you had nothing to do with that argument is,
Hey,
let me get this round.
Oh my God.
I'm going to fantasize to that tonight.
All right,
let's get back to the watch and syrup.
Checkout movement watches dot Tom.
I'm originally founded by two broke college kids movement watches.
Cut out the middle man and and their big brand retail markups in order to give
you a stylish watch,
an affordable price movement watches start at just $95 a watch with department
store quality for a fraction of the price.
They're sleek and minimalistic.
And a modern twist on a classic style movement has grown organically purely by
supporters like yourself.
So join there more than 1 million social media followers and get a movement.
Watch today.
Go to MVMT watches.com/ [inaudible] and they'll give you 15% off your entire
purchase.
MVMT watches.com/bar.
All right,
Jesus.
I hate reading out loud to all his shave club.
Everybody.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
What are we doing?
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing races right to your front two or your
backdoor.
If he could get a cool delivery guy and pays attention to the notes that you
leave,
could you leave it in the milk can around back right to your front door for a
third of the price of what the greedy razor corporations charge.
That means when you joined dollar Shave Club,
you can afford to shave with a fantastic fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels fantastic.
Um,
you get a first class shave when you use the executive blade and that's without
hurting your wallet.
And when you use the executive with Dr Carver's,
easy shave,
the blade gently glides for the smoothest shave ever.
Um,
shea butter is in your average shave cream.
It's a unique conditioning formula with high quality natural ingredients,
leaving your skin feeling unbelievably soft,
unbelievably Knuth.
Now's a great time to join dollar shave club.
New members who buy a tube of shave butter.
Get a month off the executive razor for free.
Take advantage for free.
Take advantage of this special offer.
It's available by going to dollar shave club.com/burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/burr dollar shave club.com/berm Oh God.
Here we go.
Jesus Christ.
Too many fucking reads.
All right.
Oh [inaudible] me,
undies me undies going up your fucking ass.
Bu Du,
Du,
me,
undies,
me undies.
Try to show the world you got class.
If you're in Italy and your dicks hanging out,
wouldn't it be nice to not have people shout,
put it away.
You're scaring the kids.
That's why you need me undies.
Oh yeah.
It's like a bunch of velvet on your taint.
Alright me undies.
Yeah,
but that fucking guy with the,
the fucking,
not only the Brazilian cut bathing suit,
he had the Brazilian flag on his fucking left butt cheek and he was just
straightened back and forth when,
when we were in the little fucking claustrophobic fucking fishing village,
by the way.
Um,
it's like you just start,
you just walk down this street and it just keeps getting smaller and smaller and
smaller.
And,
uh,
anyway,
she finally opens up when you get down by the ocean.
So we,
we went to,
uh,
this pizza place was sitting there and you know,
people going by on the boardwalk.
How many times did that guy walked by?
At least five,
five fucking times back and forth,
back and forth.
Then he found this woman,
I'm like,
oh,
he was looking for her and then he came walking back two seconds later without
her.
It was like,
what is this guy doing?
He was strutting around like a Brazilian peacock because what he was this little
fucking Freddie mercury underwear on,
hey,
Brazilian butt cheek.
But trying to aid a lot of Speedos,
you know,
we're,
we're in Italy is,
there's a lot of speed of bell that child,
all right,
where are we?
Okay,
we're getting near whether you're wearing his suit or sweats or you have the
Brazilian flag on your man ass spend almost 24 hours a day in your underwear.
But instead of making a statement like Superman's tights under his everyday
closure on the worst probably boring me.
And he says here to change that,
uh,
every pair of undies.
Yeah.
How would you say this word?
[inaudible].
Hmm.
Modelle
how else might you say modal?
Exactly.
That's been my fucking dilemma the entire time.
And then this is,
this is,
they go,
it's,
it's pronounced [inaudible] and it's em,
they put it in quotes,
Moh Dash d a l no doll.
How do you know it's down?
Not In moe dob because he's supposed to have that fucking accent.
Modal,
modal.
What is the context?
I'm so confused.
Every pair of me undies is made from sustainable source,
modal,
modal of fabric that's twice as soft as cotton.
They don't fucking tell you how to pronounce it.
I think they do a poor job of it and then they make this incredible fucking
boast.
And for the life of me,
I've gone on the Internet and I cannot find the studies that say that is twice
the softest cotton.
Cotton's pretty soft.
And you know,
it's like my belly right now.
Every pair of me on these is made of that shit.
Nothing can describe the fit and feel of me undies up against your under
carriage.
But once you try mine,
you'll understand why they're called the world's most comfortable underwear.
Underwear,
underwear.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And if you don't love the first pair of me undies,
they're free you.
No questions asked me.
And he says dozens of styles and limited edition prints.
Ma,
I gotta get this on the way to help make you make a statement with your
underwear.
Uh,
all right,
call to action here.
Shipping is free in the U S and Canada and you can save up to $8 a pair with the
[inaudible] subscription plan.
Get the subscription or a single pair.
Get 20% off your first order.
When you go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird that's mandy.com/burr for 20% off
your first order.
Me,
Andy's dot com slash birth
okay.
I buy underwear like once every 10 years.
You know,
I don't understand and nobody sees it.
It doesn't wear out.
I'm not singled,
so I'm not trying to take my underwear off like half does.
Excite you.
You like the fireworks around my ball bag area?
I just have black,
gray or white.
Are you bored with my underwear?
Nia.
Your Lego God.
Same Old Dick wrapped in the same old package.
I need to get some me undies.
All right.
Score big Nia.
You know what?
You're paying too much for tickets between all the markups and last minutes.
Convenience charges.
What about those assholes?
Somebody sent me a tweet so they bought tickets and there was like a $7 and they
wrote a bill burr convenience charge.
So they put it on me.
Yeah.
Why is it your fault?
No,
no,
no.
I told my agent they got to take,
don't fucking put my name on your fuck.
Overcharge.
I don't get any of that money.
Yeah.
What's in also what's convenient about it?
There's nothing convenient.
It's a fuck over and every fucking place you go to you.
That's like when I was in Saint Louis and they charged me an occupancy tax for
the hotel room I was in.
But don't they do that with every hotel?
I don't think that's a new thing.
I hate that you just said that.
Why but doesn't every rapist fucking yeah.
KCC without asking for the same thing.
In my world it is all right.
Score big.
You're paying too much for tickets between all the markups and last minute
convenient charges.
Even printed home fees.
That was a question mark with an exclamation point.
That's why I went big.
Then I was like what?
Did they have anything printed home?
It's already in the paper.
You end up paying court side prices for nosebleed seats.
Score big is here to change that.
Did you know they need it?
This is an incredible,
I still don't believe this.
Tell me,
do you know that 40% of all live event tickets go unsold?
40% near so like when Beyonce?
Yeah.
Is it Beyonce?
Beyonce,
Beyonce modal.
Hold out.
It's it's fiance but whether it be okay just go easy non yet.
You don't want the beehive coming at Ya fucking nerds.
She would walk by all of you a second.
She'd be like,
who is that bitch?
Why she backstage?
Unless you paid into her fucking thing and then she'll pretend to like it.
That's my gut instinct.
Um,
did you know that 40% of all life event tickets going sold?
And did you know that there's a place to get these seats at huge savings?
It's called ScoreBig.
Yeah.
Like when they had the Superbowl knee of 40% of those tickets go on sale old.
Why?
Everybody wants to go.
Thank God this ScoreBig ScoreBig works directly with your favorite teams and
artists.
Oh so they hold back 40% of these fucking chicken.
Really never want to have advertisers on this part.
You can get there on salts cause this is insulting.
40% of tickets of every live event do not go unsold.
You fucking assholes.
Yeah.
If you're going to go see the bgs cause there's only,
there's only one left BG and Beyonce of this that
that's like the old dead fucking choke from Larry Sanders.
I was going to say they should just call him BG now cause it's just one left.
And that was like,
remember when Hank said that when Ashley Joe Wynonna Judd came on and he
introduced her as the Judd cause she used to be in the Judds and he's like,
she's had stay with a judge.
She's a judge.
You don't remember that.
Anyways,
here's what you got to do.
Got score.com download the new score big APP for your iPhone and find the events
and seats.
You want to make an offer with score.
Big ticket name a ticket price feature.
All right,
give me a dollar.
I want to to the Superbowl for a dollar.
You get an instant answer.
Go Fuck yourself and save up 60% on your tickets.
Never any fees in shipping is always free.
You can count on unbeatable prices and great seats and when you're in great
seats you actually enjoyed the game or the show.
All the more,
oh my God,
look at Beyonce.
I can almost smell for the easiest for the easiest way.
I know I'm not trying to me,
I know she's fierce for the easiest way to save on tickets.
Download the new score,
big APP for your iPhone.
Enter the Promo Code [inaudible] at checkout at checkout,
and you'll save an extra $20 off your first ticket price.
No iPhone,
no problem.
Get $20 off online.
Uh,
two@scorebig.com that's got a big.com.
Promo Code Birth Score,
big.com Promo Code Burr.
All right,
that was the last one.
Ah,
Thank God.
Um,
who do you think's better?
And he had lady Gaga.
Beyonce.
Madonna.
Okay.
Or that,
that check you skilled,
cheeky,
whatever the fuck she do.
And then she played it.
She played the Flamenco Guitar.
Uh,
can I rank them as far as the CIO?
Who's Beth?
Well,
isn't that what you're doing?
Yeah.
You're talking about an ally of aspect.
I've only seen two of those four examples live to the CIC plane,
the Flamenco guitarist.
Fucking unbelief.
Gyro is amazing.
All right,
we love Johno Jan.
Dot.
Medina please.
Guitar.
She's like wearing driving gloves so she's not even taking it seriously.
So she's all right.
I never seen Madonna lab.
I'd like to know lady Gaga was a meat dress while she's on a horse.
It's a real horse.
Right.
That's not what happened when people take their tits up now,
Beyonce,
Beyonce.
I've never seen him.
Amazing.
She's going.
Time I see a live is when she falls down because the clip shows up on my youtube
when she's doing that thing,
she's whipping her head around my youtube,
whatever.
You go on the homepage and then it's just like,
oh well you watched,
you watched this slap fight is a frog kicking a fly in the face and then you're
like,
oh,
watch that.
And the next thing you know you watch in frog fly videos and then somehow it
comes back.
It always ends up coming back around to when Beyonce fell down the stairs.
That's how it works for me.
Hmm.
I haven't seen those other two and I think it'd be honest,
they definitely gave them better
concert then Gaga
near Renee Hill.
Throwing shade,
I believe is what they say.
That was not throwing shade.
We toss it,
toss the shade.
There is no shame in that statement.
Did you sent put the shade down on the pillow?
Like a mint?
Um,
all right.
What else did I want to talk about?
Oh,
you know what?
I'm obsessed with the car over here.
I'm in Italy.
Near what car am I going to be obsessed by the Ferrari?
No,
the Lamborghini now.
Yeah,
that the fee at 500 cc pictures of everyone that you've seen but two cylinder
fucking engine,
motorcycle engine basically.
And a was considered a four passenger back in the day and they're just fucking
most of the door.
I love those little cards.
I love smart cars.
Does it such cool?
That's like when you were a little kid and you had a little fake gold card that
your mom had a push you around and,
but you know she was too sleepy because she was having a bunch of kids.
Now here is why a smart,
the only,
the only reason why is you saying all the obvious things people say about a
smart card.
The only reason I smart car stinks is because there's truck drivers texting.
That's why it stinks because you know the car is already half mushed up.
But as far as just like,
okay,
just a great guy,
just jumped in the fucking car.
You can park it anywhere where,
I dunno,
I like it.
I can appreciate a Ferrari.
All we done with smart car,
you just,
I just hate people who look at a smart car and they're just so like they compare
it to like a fucking,
you know,
some sort of race car,
you know what I mean?
It's,
it's like that's not what it's trying to deal.
Right.
Okay.
I don't know.
Whatever.
I like that car.
So I liked the little fee at 500 cc and what I learned,
I was on the old ones and you have to do this technique is called uh,
a double clutch.
And I was sitting there,
I've never understood that.
And I had to drive a truck one time on breaking bad and when I had to pull up in
the dump truck and the guy was trying to show me how to do the double clutch
thing,
which is weird because when you want to up shift it's like you got to let the
things slow down the,
the rotations of the slow down and when you downshift,
you actually got to hit the gas and have it speed up,
which makes no fucking sense to me.
I would think it would be the opposite.
So it was fucking me up.
Safari go dude.
Why aren't I just fucking leave it in gear?
All right.
I'll give it throttle and I let out the clutch and I'll just go.
You just said finally said yes to that.
But ever since then like I had idea,
but I
still have to tell you,
even just driving that dump truck and like first gear for like 10 feet into the
shot was one of the coolest things I ever did.
Hmm.
Yeah.
That's like the little kid shit.
Like you have a big giant Tonka truck.
Um,
didn't you also have to like stand on train tracks?
I'm breaking bad or wait,
are you pretending to be a train conductor?
Oh No,
the train.
Yeah.
No,
we robbed the train.
I had to stop the train.
So the,
the other guys see,
uh,
I almost said Mr Pink,
Jesse Pinkman and Mr. White robbed it in the back.
Right,
right,
right.
That's what it,
yes.
So the funniest part of that,
my most fun of that scene other than driving it was when they were just shooting
me.
And I had to pretend there was a train coming at me and there was no train
there.
And one of the conductors,
one of the actors was just laughing his ass off because he knew I had to do the
scene.
And that's just one of the things that's going to be an entire crew of people
watching you not saying anything and they go action.
And you have to like in the middle of nowhere,
stand on these train tracks and scream and yell and there's nobody fucking,
yeah.
Yeah.
Great acting experience because it prepared me for more shit like that.
Like so good on breaking bad.
You would have been good on breaking bad.
It was the writing.
Anybody would have been great on breaking bad the supposed to man.
I mean like anybody who will be fucking good on it.
Yeah,
but you were like,
you would be great on breaking bad.
I fucking did it.
A two episode
show.
One a Netflix series that's premiering next year.
May I point out I was being fucking modest when he told you you were great on
Brinkmann.
Yeah I was wasn't I know you just say thank you.
Is it that hard?
You are the worst thing of a compliments you because you literally just don't
know what to do.
You can't just say thank you.
You're always like,
Hey,
well what are you going to do?
I got lucky.
You get a spot.
But it's the simplest response is thank you.
And you just can't seem to wrap your mind around it.
I've seen it happen so many times of people.
Oh my God,
you're amazing.
You're like,
Hey,
well you know I just showed up to say thank you.
What's so hard?
Cause it's fucking weird.
Why is it weird to get a compliment?
Oh,
Boston,
you know,
speaking of what you all fuck,
I forgot who I ran into.
Who I fucking ran into,
right.
Oh,
so I fucking,
um,
in Belgium and I'm going up the stairs and of course my fucking,
uh,
key doesn't work and to go on this big,
long fucking stupid fucking technology.
Who the fuck is he speaking?
Fucking easy.
You mean we can see the key?
Okay.
Cell phone touches a key.
The key is to work in.
I was just being such a fucking baby and then it went down there and it turned
out I had the wrong key because this other key was for something else in there.
But then still it's like,
you know what the fuck?
You know,
just give me one fucking key assholes.
Right.
So I turn around.
Okay.
And what man,
this fucking guy,
okay.
Stands up.
He's got the eighties rock star fucking hair.
He's in great shape.
And I just looked at him and I go,
Holy Shit.
I just looked at him.
I go,
are you Tommy Aldridge?
And he goes,
yeah.
And I was just like,
and I literally yelled,
I was like,
I had a normal voice.
I go,
you told me all do.
And he goes,
yeah.
And then I just go,
no way
in the fucking loving.
I don't know when,
dude,
I got all your DVDs.
I was trying to say,
I still have,
I actually have his drum instructional,
uh,
fucking I have it on VHS tape.
I ever,
I bet for the VC area,
um,
I could see it in his face.
He was just going,
oh no,
this person's crazy.
How am I going to get out of this?
And I just stuck my hand up.
I just say,
hey man,
thanks for [inaudible].
I said,
uh,
just,
I just said,
thanks for all your great drama over the years and as he's walking away and just
said thanks.
That's what just reminded me of that.
Yeah.
Simple.
Thank you.
Give him a moment.
Yeah.
So it was actually,
I want to say,
I mean,
I'm prejudice here.
I think it was a good fan interaction with them.
Yeah.
For him.
I didn't ask him for an autograph.
I just shook his hand.
Right.
Plus who flips out when they see a drummer.
Other drummers.
Right.
Okay.
We'll just get played with fucking Ozzie.
Uh Huh.
Played and Whitesnake he played like every fucking band that I listened to
coming up.
Whitesnake I always like,
what was their big head?
Are they uh,
everybody liked?
Here I go again.
Yes.
No,
no,
haven't,
no.
Um,
that's how he sings it now.
When you went down,
it's ever no nick,
if he goes never known.
What was that?
What was that song of or watching VH one classic
Ben.
Keep going.
Yeah.
You killed a will cause that's the way he does it.
That was
I,
no,
Oh,
you look so much emotion in that was queens,
right?
Queens,
right.
Yeah.
I don't know what,
there wasn't there.
There was like,
right,
like art,
I like the third,
right.
I think more like middle earth,
they were more like,
oh,
I don't know.
I don't fucking know and understand science fiction,
but I do know that it was like two types of heavy metal bands.
There was,
there was like the people who were just like,
hey man,
like let's get some booze and fucks some strippers.
Right?
Like Motley Crue,
there was
a poison and all of those guys.
Not saying that,
I'm not lumping them all together.
I'm just saying there was the party fucking bans.
And then there was the,
the ones that were more like in the issues.
Do you know what I mean?
Both.
Like,
you know,
your noble,
Noble.
I was trying to think as,
I'm trying to think of something that,
who saying somebody's
death?
That was def Leppard.
Yeah.
That was def Leppard when they became a pop band.
Since she's mad shit.
Uh,
that was,
uh,
there wasn't a lot of the white bands that was not white snake.
It was no national.
You mean there wasn't Whitesnake.
It wasn't white blinds.
Oh,
that wasn't,
what,
what the fuck
was there a name?
She's mad.
She,
Amy.
Oh,
it was a w Warren Warren.
Yeah.
But on my belt,
those were the WWE bands.
And then was,
there was Warren that was winger
and there was a
blow.
Those were all the white pants,
white snake,
white lion,
great white.
It always happens.
It's like in the 60s there was the Beatles,
the animals,
the fucking rascals.
Everything became the,
the,
some,
the monkeys whose all animal names and then the early two thousands,
it was all numbers,
right?
Late nineties,
matchbox 23.
Mary,
wait,
so the monk to have buy land where they are supported by a satirize Beatles.
What was the deal with the monkeys?
They were like a manufactured band.
Right?
But were they meant to be
face and I'm a believer.
He's bad man,
man.
Amen.
Ah,
all right.
This is becoming like a slumber party when
not everybody's on vacation right now.
So this is not going to be cute for long.
Alright,
here we go.
All right,
let me,
uh,
let's read some questions.
Let's get back to the real world where people ask a,
an illiterate comedian for life advice.
Alright,
Rodriguez.
Hey Bill,
I listened to your podcast and we'd like your opinion,
which I assume you will hit anyways regarding him.
He's like the cheating husband that happens to make too much for that client to
leave him.
Why if he it.
Um,
and he's just trying to be funny.
Yeah,
it's,
it's an expression.
It's a,
it's a term of endearment.
It's a term of endearment.
I see.
Not We're not in fucking England or they just,
I don't know if Allison,
I don't know if Alex Rodriguez for tired then I just seen his name keep popping
up.
I don't know what happened.
I don't know.
Being a red sox fan,
I'm wondering what your opinion is.
I'm not a big baseball fan so I could give two fucks.
So you don't care.
You just
want my opinion.
But Kirby pocket wasn't such a con,
aside from supposedly raping some chicken arrested.
What are you doing here?
Ah,
yeah,
he was and still is loved and adored in the twin cities.
Explain the difference and get your ass here as soon as possible so I can bring
someone to see you.
I look forward.
Thank you.
Well,
let me see if Alex Rodrigues retired.
What?
I really don't have any opinion on a rock.
After 2004 once the red sox won the world series,
I don't give a shit about the Yankees.
So was the end of the movie.
It's the end of the fucking movie.
Whenever they have 27 championships,
we're never going to catch him.
But they can't rub it in our face that we haven't won one.
We won the fucking three.
It's,
it's,
it's over.
You know what I mean?
It was like back to the future.
They should have stopped.
But the first one they just kept going.
Then all of a sudden was the 18 hundreds they made two and three at the same
time.
He and Derek Jeter,
I always get confused.
They're both Yankee is right.
They're both really handsome and they date famous girls.
MMM,
right.
Well,
personally I always like Tina.
Oh,
it's another fucking project.
Both really handsome.
He,
what are you talking about over?
Yeah.
All right,
Alex.
A rod.
Yeah,
he's good looking.
And then Derek Jeter,
they're both like Rodriguez,
obviously like Latino.
Derek Jeter is like biracial or something.
They're both like any colored.
Right.
And you're
ruining both of these people for a lot of men right now.
All right.
What is my opinion on the guy
as one of them dated Mariah?
Or
let's just move onto the next question.
Oh,
all right.
What?
I don't understand what it lets you parked.
Yes.
And would like your opinion,
which I assume I feel like he's a not comfortable in his own skin and he doesn't
know what to say.
And now that,
that Derek Jeter,
the guy who was totally comfortable in his own skin and never fucked up is gone.
I think he could just sort of fucking chill out and I'm happy for him.
You can just kind of fucking,
you know,
just VA right.
Whenever.
I hope he has a good season.
Not when he plays the Red Sox,
but you know,
I don't give up.
It's over.
We won the world series.
Go Fuck Yourself.
We ran the tape.
I'm familiar.
I'm a happy sportster.
All right.
Connor Mcgee.
I know he's not Scottish.
Stop treating me
Billy blood.
Uh,
did you hear Mcgregor talking shit about John [inaudible].
He went on,
he went on a rant.
About how we respects the old WWF but doesn't give a shit about the new guys
because they're all sissies.
He calls Siena a 40 year old grandmother.
What universe is a 40 year old grandmother?
I'm in a 40 year old.
Could be a grandmother,
but Jesus,
how old is coming?
Oh,
what's great.
As key.
Such a bad ass.
And he can actually say that about a guy.
He's big as John Senior who I imagine it has a wrestling background.
Some of these guys that get into the WWF actually like,
like Ken per terror I remember was like he won an Olympic gold medal for
wrestling.
Um,
a of them like at the collegiate level.
Like we're champions so they actually know what the fuck they're doing.
So their ground game was pretty good,
I would think,
you know.
Anyways,
he says,
I'm sure Mcgregor could take punches better,
but seeing it as much stronger.
Uh,
who do you think would win and do you think Mcgregor is a Douche bag?
Have you talked to Joe Rogan about this?
Joe Rogan has a busy man.
I haven't talked to him about what you think about Johnson.
Go on.
I'm like,
good guy.
Josie and I was in movies and commercials now anyway.
He's not even like in reality shows like he's not even like actively fighting.
Please just so say he's,
he's honey colored.
Just just don't say that again.
All right.
He's not so I wouldn't mix
and it shouldn't you like go down to the pool or something.
Oh,
now you want to kick me out of the box?
Yeah.
Cause you turning everything into like,
uh,
look what's happening now with the gay guy in the fucking old broads with the
boat.
Talk to their face.
What's the name of that show?
I don't know.
Hi,
I'm,
I'm fucking,
I'm trying,
I'm dressed like I'm from the south and I'm going to make these fucking Jersey
broads getting mad at each other.
Okay.
Are you talking about Andy Cohen?
They go watch what happens live.
Yeah,
you'd go,
okay,
look,
look what these bitches are yelling about now.
He just stirs him up.
He does.
He's like Captain Lou Albano.
Um,
he calls seen a 40 year old that the one with the rubber bands on his beard.
Yeah.
Rest in peace.
But it wasn't the Cindy lopper his video.
He played her dad and the girls just wanna have one video.
Sorry.
Need a hell everybody.
Hey,
thanks for coming by the podcast.
I'll see you all right.
I'm done.
No,
you're not get out,
but isn't that question
I could answer that.
The next one.
I'll be quiet for the rest of the segment.
Okay.
All right.
So what do I think about it?
I think he's just being Conor McGregor and that's why you fucking love the guy
who sells fights.
He's fucking hilarious.
Colon John's seen a 40 year old grandmothers hilarious that I imagine he'll say
something funny back and it'll be great.
You know,
I don't know.
No one,
Conor Mcgregor,
I don't think he plans out.
What the fuck he says.
I just think he goes up there and he goes off like a comedian that's in the
zone.
I think he's fucking hilarious.
Um,
now and now I've got to go find that.
Uh,
I got to go find that clip.
All right.
Can Women go to bachelor parties?
Oh God.
What?
What is this going to become a thing?
All right.
Hey Billy blue balls.
I'd like your advice on a disagreement.
My best friend and I are having,
he's getting married next fall and we are very close.
We've been great friends since college and we are so close to that.
So close that him and his fiance just asked me to officiate their wedding.
The disagreement is about whether I should be able to go to his bachelor party
in Vegas.
I'm a woman,
but because he's my best friend,
I think I should be able to go.
He wants to bachelor party to be men only.
And I understand this to to a point but at the same time,
but virtue of how close we are,
I think I should be able to go,
uh,
my friend and I are big friends of your podcasts and have agreed that if you
read this on air,
whatever your advice is,
we'll take it.
So if you don't think that I,
the best female friend should be going to the bachelor party.
We agree to it.
Love the podcast.
Oh,
become to Boston soon.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Um,
no you shouldn't because I thought first I thought this was a guy going to be
bitching about his male friend that wanted to bring a woman along.
And the first thing I was going to say,
it would be like,
I don't agree with that,
but at the end of the day,
it's this person's bachelor party.
It's their wedding.
So you just gotta you know,
I would just shut up about it,
but I would break his balls for the rest of time.
Like this is my best friend.
He had a woman at his bachelor party.
No,
it wasn't a stripper.
So I would give the same advice here.
Um,
this is not your bachelor party and this is not a time for you to throw a hissy
fit and ruin this thing for him.
He has a bachelor party the way he wants.
I think it's really cool that you guys are best friends and that you're going to
see is,
I think it's enough of an honor that he,
he's going to let you speak,
you know,
as his best man.
I mean that's pretty fucking amazing.
Officiate whatever.
Oh,
you're going to do the vials?
Yeah.
Okay.
She's going to officiate the ones.
Oh,
all right.
Yeah,
there you go.
That's huge.
And you go,
there you go.
Yeah,
so,
and I,
I was,
do you care what I think only if you agree with me,
I agree with you and that's why this relationship works.
I totally agree with you.
Okay.
My wife and I can understand why she'd want to go because it's like,
Hey,
I'm your friend.
I want to go.
But like,
just say what you say.
Don't stir her fucking brain up again.
All right.
You shouldn't go.
Yes.
Respect your best friend wishes and Naco cause he's going to want to do some
shit.
Hey.
Yeah,
you don't,
you don't that you don't get extra credit.
You don't get extra credit for saying,
I already said,
all right.
Every once in a while to meet and I just,
all right,
my wife is a Gremlin.
Hey Billy Bongos,
my wife of just over a year.
It was adorable and everybody loves her most days.
She is a hardworking,
levelheaded human.
I consider myself to have similar characteristics in though and through hard
work have become quite successful because of this success.
We have a 40 to become somewhat of a socialite couple.
We attend several parties and events on a monthly basis.
This all sounds like the beginning of Boogie Nights,
doesn't it?
And then she starts doing below next to now she's getting banged in the
driveway.
He's just sitting there going,
what the fuck's going on?
That's nothing like Buddy Matt.
Oh,
I don't know.
That's what I'm picturing because there were a socialite couple,
then they're going to get into the cocaine couple thing.
Oh,
I think I see what you're doing with this.
All right.
So we attend several parties and events on a monthly basis.
Normally all goes well and we go to bed happy and peaceful.
But every now and then my adorable wife turns evil.
Um,
I already pictured her,
her catching him,
looking at the fucking hottie.
So you go to a social light party,
you're testing the limits of your fucking relationship.
That's when he said he,
they did a bad,
bad thing,
right?
You stuck in all those fucking eyes wide shut party.
That's what you're doing.
Yeah.
All of those fucking people,
they look at women that like objects and shit and it's just like they give her
the old flicker,
the eyebrow,
meaning you want to fuck mine and I'll fuck yours.
I've never been to one of these parties,
but that's,
that's what I think.
That's what I think goes down.
All right.
You want to fuck man,
I'll fuck yours.
Well,
we both just watch them go down on each other as we discussed stocks.
All right.
Normally all goes well and we go to bed happy and peaceful.
But every now and then my adorable wife turns evil.
It's a little like the movie gremlins.
I've narrowed it down.
If she's boozed hungry and tired after midnight,
she turns into a class a cunt.
She,
she's mean to me.
But what is it worth is she says,
evil thinks about others.
To me,
the result is I am the only person that gets to see and hear this Gremlin and
action and it makes me crazy.
It makes me want to buy her a pair of cement shoes and a boat.
Kidding.
I think.
Okay.
I'm an m so what do I do?
We have talked about it several times the next day with level head,
but Gizmo continues to turn from time to time.
Do I start caring Bruno?
I was just going to say I don't,
I have a sandwich in my back pocket.
Do I start carrying granola bars and a five hour energies and my pockets like,
Eh,
what does that work?
Okay.
Like an Epi pen.
Uh,
what is that?
That's where people who have allergies or nut allergies or do I cut off for
booze and General?
The lovely Nia you have any,
any input?
Okay.
Uh,
bring your a game to gains fill until then go fuck yourself.
all right.
Sorry.
It's just reading that last little bit he had there.
Um,
what would I do?
I Dunno.
I would,
yeah.
I think I would just start bringing snacks and I would start,
I would start calling her the Gremlin.
I,
what's the word you use or just,
yeah,
just,
just when she starts getting into that social,
just being like,
Hey Gizmo to take it down a notch.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
I would literally feed her like a rabid dog.
You don't if they have a rabid dog ever came running out,
you know,
cause that's what you supposed to do.
He's supposed to throw raw steak at him.
Right.
Is that we spoke last night as I have a rustic on you at all times.
That's a black guy.
If you get a black guy,
you put a rustic I,
you said Black Guy
as oh put black guy.
The black guy comes at you.
You just throw a rustic.
Ah,
wouldn't it be great if everybody,
if everybody wasn't meat eaters and they liked it rare,
then you wouldn't have to cook it and you just walk around and I'm going to the
store and you just had stakes with you.
If there was any fucking problems,
sir,
would you like to sign up for this cell phone?
He just fucking throw it out and I found this.
They were just runaway costs.
You too much money though.
All right.
I thought there was some comedy there.
There wasn't.
You can't cut off her booze unless you just decided to not go to these events
with her and we'll make sure you guys have a nice dinner before you go out.
I would just break her balls the entire time over there and be like,
so what do you think?
What do you think when do turned into Gizmo tonight?
Around 1130 or 1145 absolutely.
Gizmo Gizmo.
Look at you going crazy.
Your teeth are all pointing now.
What's going on with you?
All right,
one more.
This is becoming long here.
How long has it now our 12 here we go.
Alright,
move back to east coast bill.
As your success continues and you become even more financially stable and set
for the longterm,
that is an impossibility.
I don't understand how you get financially cause at the end of the day,
even if you just take all your money and you stick it in a bank,
what those cons do is at some point they play a little fucking fucking,
they loan everything out.
I will never forget just watching people with their life savings in there
standing outside the bank and that's just a pad lock on it.
So there's really no place that you can put it.
Every place you put it,
someone's going to put their fucking hands on it.
You know what I mean?
You stick it in the stock market,
they start investing it.
They just like,
it's so fucked up.
They won't just let you have your money.
The only way to do it is if you fucking just cashed your check every week and
you stuck it in the wall and then you got to worry like,
did I leave the iron on?
Every time you leave or someone gets winded.
That's what you'd do it.
And then you got to have the shotgun bed.
You've ever seen the shotgun bed?
No.
It's the greatest fucking bed in the world.
If you live alone,
it's basically,
it's the,
the,
the headboard.
You bring your hands back like this.
As you touch it,
the thing flips around like a secret door and a loaded shotgun comes down in
your hand.
That's a real thing.
Yeah.
That's also made from a movie.
It's the fucking shit.
But it's the thing,
whenever they show the demonstration,
the persons in the bed by themselves.
Okay.
Because when it comes down,
the fucking barrel is going to be pointing at your wife at her head.
Yeah.
That sounds dangerous.
Well what she gotta do?
What?
You got to sleep on the side of the bed.
If you're a left handed shot her right shot.
You got to sit on the side of the bed.
Where if in your view panic,
you know what I mean?
Like if you woke up in the middle of the night and you looked over and there was
just this figure standing there and the door,
like that horror movie,
you know,
in the late,
and then she turns the lights on and then she turns it off and then it's there.
Then she turns it on,
she turns it off and it moved up like 10 feet and it's like,
bitch lead the fucking lights on a trailer because that's exactly what I think.
Why do you keep flicking it on?
Maybe cause you're like,
am I seeing what I'm really seeing when it moves up though?
That is the ship.
It's scary,
but I can't,
I can't deal with that.
You know,
something I hate,
people don't buy into horror movies.
I always buy it.
I'm like,
all right,
I get it.
Yeah.
She's flipping the lights on.
Never happen.
Real life.
Yeah.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
the only way I could see that you're,
you're financially fucking set as you buy a house and you fucking pay it off.
All right.
You know,
the rest of this thing.
Okay.
You had any thoughts about what point you would have to get to before you move
back to the east coast?
I know that Nia may not be fond of this and you may not be thinking about it
either,
but it seems like you would be happier backing.
But who the fuck is this idiot?
You don't know me?
Yeah,
you don't know me.
You don't know why I like Boston new,
et cetera.
I'm from Pittsburgh originally and lived in Chicago for a few years and now I'm
in Washington DC area,
so I never lived on the west coast,
but have visited numerous times.
You can't beat the weather in la,
but you can't beat the culture of the east coast.
We'd love to hear your thoughts and thank you for keeping us all entertained.
No complaining about La a lot.
No,
not at all.
I love the thing that you'd be happier back in Boston because people,
I get one by the time I'd read the rest of it,
I get it.
He's just looking at the world through his own eyes.
Um,
I dunno,
I,
I sometimes I think about moving back east,
but I mean I'm doing f is for family.
The show business is out there.
Um,
and this fucking great people in La.
This is great food.
There's all this great stuff to do out there.
A lot of people,
shit on La Cause when they move out there,
you know,
they try to make it in show business and they don't get,
they don't get anywhere and they'd pack it in and they leave.
All they really met was a bunch of other desperate people that didn't get
anywhere.
And it can give you a really bad feeling about La.
I've had that experience too.
The first time I went out there,
um,
you know,
I was like full killed.
All the real people are on the east coast.
I started having that eye,
that attitude.
But you know,
when you go out there,
when you break through,
like,
and you start meeting people like someone like really most talented,
generous,
cool fucking people I've met have been when I've been out there.
And,
uh,
you know,
I mean,
nine times out of 10 if you meet somebody legendary,
you quickly realize why they were fucking legend.
And that's because of,
uh,
their,
their attitude.
Like they,
they've made all this money that really super successful and they're still like
genuinely interested in new things and don't feel it.
They know everything and that type of shit.
And UHM,
I dunno,
you can't beat the fucking houses out there are awesome.
Yeah.
I don't know.
You've never once complained about living in la.
If anything you're like,
I love it out here.
And I also love New York.
I love New York,
but like,
yeah,
uh,
you know,
if I was having to move back to New York,
I mean at this point I'd have to live in a house.
Like once you live in a house,
you can't go back to living in a fucking apartment.
I traipsing up and down the fucking stairs and,
and just living in New York,
you have no car.
You just like this prisoner of the neighborhood and you just sitting there dying
for new restaurants to open up.
Just,
I just remember that.
And then you've got this little ass fucking kitchen and you're,
you're watching.
Like I used to watch molto Mario and I'm like,
I'm going to buy one of those.
I want to buy one of those.
And then I,
I had no place to put it and all these pots and pans stacked up.
I can't do it.
New York City's for young people,
you know?
And if you don't believe me,
look at the older people that live there and look at their postures and shit.
Like,
I don't know,
I love New York,
but I couldn't go.
I don't know that I'd want to live there again.
Not In the city at least.
Yeah.
I just,
I,
I feel like that part of my life is all,
yeah,
it was fun in my twenties yeah.
I roller bladed on all those avenues,
but a fear,
if we ever went back,
I would,
I would get up,
I'd get a house and I just drive into the city.
Yeah.
Like in Bitch,
Moan and complain about the fucking traffic.
Exactly.
I was like,
you live in the suburbs in Westchester or whatever.
I wouldn't mind that.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's a possibility by me,
you know,
I kind of feel like I'm going to do this cartoon and I'm going to be ready to
just be like,
all right,
if this thing goes like,
you know,
seven,
eight seasons.
That's it.
What else?
What else more do you need to do?
I went out to la.
I got a TV show.
We did it for eight seasons.
People liked it.
I made people laugh and then what I would do the Seinfeld.
Yes.
Do the same.
Yeah.
Then I do my fucking,
my,
my drum solo.
A fucking comedy show.
Right.
All right.
Thank you guys for listening.
This is the podcast.
Uh,
go fuck yourselves and I will talk to you a little late in the war the week when
I check in on.
Yes.